for 12 hours crime will be legal what
the [ __ ] are you gonna do the purge I
was super excited for this movie just
such a great what-if concept what if we
were allowed to do whatever we wanted
for 12 hours does it cross the line of
morality the law but the question is
how's the [ __ ] execution well I am
proud to tell you that it is just okay
yes this movie managed to create a world
take you on a my trippin experience to
go wow what would I do and yet it just
turns into a home invasion shoot him up
movie I got a lot of [ __ ] issues with
this movie example 8 the king yes that
is a boy despite whatever you might
think this is a boy who looks like a
girl have you ever met a boy who is so
smart yet managed to be so stupid before
here's my main issue none of this [ __ ]
would have happened if it wasn't for
this goddamn kid and then he has a
sister a whiny annoying fifteen-year-old
sister with a stupid boyfriend who
growls see the first half of this movie
was really good actually and I in a lot
of ways not always but really good for
the most part it explores a lot of the
concept and then it sort of becomes sort
of a tension type of thriller the last
type of this film just becomes a
shoot-'em-up movie there's no tension no
fear as a matter of fact there's no fear
throughout any of this movie none of it
is scary none of it is really not
thrilling but the most disappointing
part of it is how can you create such a
good concept but not really explore it
it's like imagine Natalie Portman is
laying on your bed
butt-naked legs spread open and
everything and she's like [ __ ] me Ryan
right [ __ ] me and then I don't [ __ ] her
that is what this movie is like it is
not having sex with its content I don't
think - I don't really get what the
purpose of this film was no one really
grows there's some people descend I
don't really feel like people learn
anything from this whole experience and
just
honestly is the [ __ ] kid he's just so
goddamn annoying okay honestly he's a
good actor he does a good job with the
role it's just the way they wrote him
honestly a lot of the writings kind of
week there's a lot of really wooden
dialogue here's the first ten minutes
I'm gonna give it to you right now the
purge tonight help the purge it's
happening be safe you're gonna be safe
even though it's the purge but you're
gonna be safe the purge safe purge two
lines of dialogue repeated between like
15 different people also I thought it
was kind of racist that they make the
black guy the reason everything gets
[ __ ] up in this movie why not a Jew
there's something but the house may have
lost my drag oh I'm just [ __ ] with
you honestly look I know my reviews all
over the place it's just this film is
just a really big letdown I hate it when
there's such an original idea yet its
execution is not on par with its
potential it should have been a better
movie at first it has a lot of great
stuff within the last half it just
canceled that becomes a typical home
invasion movie it's just a ripoff of
movies like Straw Dogs strangers and
even that straight-to-dvd movie trespass
with Nicolas Cage in Nicole Kidman yes I
apparently watched that movie trespass a
movie that no one else saw I feel so
lonely great concept
poor execution let me get straight to
the point here oh no I gotta say the
purge got it wrong
alright guys thanks for checking out my
review for the purge why don't you go
ahead skull that comment box below and
tell me if the purge was real would you
actually murder people would you and
more importantly who would you murder
please list their names telephone number
address whatever information you got on
them and if you want to see a more
in-depth review of the purge go ahead
and check out my show called reasons to
see with guest star Thomas forgot the
guy's last name and Jerry a guy with no
last name both on the show with me and
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time one of my reviews is
out go ahead and subscribe to my channel
by clicking on the link right here if
you don't click on it and then the day
the purge becomes real I will find you
and kick you in the face and tell you
hey you should have subscribed [ __ ]